was was that first step for you was do
you do you recall kind of some of your
early goals was it simply to find some
level of success some level of security
do you remember what those first steps
were for
you well it it was um it was more a
passion you know like I like this thing
and I don't like the other things and I
would right pursue pursue what I liked
uh in my particular case I happened to
like the markets so I got hooked on the
markets and it happened to be a game
think of it like almost a video game and
I got used to that that and then it
takes me like a video game does it took
me through all the um Adventures um this
is what life is like uh you pursue a
path that there's a passion or
something um in which you have you have
a certain nature every one has a certain
nature and that nature creates a pull
and you're in search of your path and
your pull so I had my
nature that gave me my pull I found a
direction and it's not like there's just
one direction there are multiple
directions that would work but many that
also you know wouldn't work it's a
function in nature I had the pull in
that direction and then think of it as a
journey you know you overcome you go
through jungles and you cross rivers and
you have all sorts of obstacles and so
on and along the way you um have those
encounters and those learnings um that
was what it felt like for me and as I um
did that though it was the excitement of
that Journey that pull and I like to
overcome the obstacle and I I dealt with
the ups and downs and so on it was never
that I
pursued a goal to make a lot of money
though at various stages it was very
important that I could take care of my
family Money Matters M money didn't
matter and all but by and large it was
that pull driven by my nature and my
encounters and then getting excellent
better at it each time and becoming more
and more excellent and then I find
myself in the position I find myself in